[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti Sono davvero
emozionata di essere qui con voi questa
sera
per parlare di qualcosa che
può sembrare un po' in contrapposizione
no Golosi e longevi perché
diceva le cose più belle della vita o
sono immorali o sono illegali oppure
fanno ingrassare siete d'accordo
è ancora attuale Noi ci troviamo a
Bologna
città identificata con la cucina
buonissima Tant'è vero che tra
gli aggettivi con cui si
descrive questa città si dice Bologna
la grassa Proprio perché le cose più
buone sono anche le cose più grasse
Allora quando io mi presento magari tra
persone che con cui ancora non ci si
conosce Ah tu che cosa fai Io sono
nutrizionista vedo a volte il volto
tendersi no
dell'interlocutore lo stomaco chiudersi
Perché Perché
nutrizione salute
Cosa vuol dire voi quando sentite la
parola nutrizionista vi viene in mente
una carbonara o una mela verde
Ecco no Ecco io qui ho portato
una ciambella fritta No qui ho fatto
merenda oggi pomeriggio prima di venire
qui quindi una nutrizionista viene più
identificata con una ciambella fritta o
con uno yogurt
con lo yogurt no e tutti voi forse il
90% di voi avranno già
sperimentato e la dissociata e la
chetogenica e toglie il carboidrato e
carboidrato soltanto a pranzo a cena no
la dieta del ghiaccio
c'è qualcuno di voi che non ha mai fatto
una dieta
Ecco qualcuno si salva Bene bene sono i
più felici di questa di questa platea
e quindi ecco sì Facciamo un passo
indietro
quando io facevo l'università scopro di
avere il colesterolo a 297 non so se
qualcuno di voi sa una persona di 20
anni che ha 300 di colesterolo mi prendo
un colpo Allora faccio rifare le analisi
dicono ma ci sarà un errore
300 Quindi più o meno Allora chiamo mia
madre dico io come mi hanno presentato
studiamo all'estero studiamo in Spagna e
chiamo mia madre mamma Io c'ho 300 di
colesterolo ti preoccupa' nonna c'ha 500
c'abbiamo tutti come si capisce sono
bolognesi di adozione ma di origini
romane e quindi e quindi ecco che
improvvisamente diventa una mia prima
paziente comincio a dire Chiara tu stai
studiando nutrizione devi essere
bravissima senza medicine tutti
abbasserai il colesterolo Ed ecco che
comincia il mio Calvario auto inflitto
Quindi io golosissima niente più dolci
niente più formaggi niente più fritti
niente più carbonara niente più di
niente e comincia lo strazio che quando
mangiavo l'insalatona
sognavo la carbonara
quando mangiavo il dolce
il senso di colpa potrei mangiare il
dolce Ma adesso che succede domani sulla
bilancia perché tra l'altro scopro anche
di avere l'ipotiroidismo che è una
patologia che ti blocca il metabolismo
quindi chi soffre di ipotiroidismo tende
ad ingrassare con la velocità
supersonica Ecco che comincia questo
calvario ma facciamo un altro passo
indietro ci portiamo nel 2007 Sono
passati già 15 anni quindi potete fare
un po' di calcoli da quando Da quando
avevo iniziato l'università e quindi
nel 2007 stavo nelle corsie di un
ospedale Mi occupavo di diabete e
avviene qualcosa che mi cambia la vita
cosa avviene una mia paziente mi
avvicina dopo una riunione di gruppo e
mi dice quasi piangendo
dottoressa
non mi tolga la lasagna
io senza lasagna non vivo Mi dica lei
come devo cucinarla ma non mi tocca non
mi tolga la lasagna
Allora questa supplica mi lascia senza
parole perché
torno a casa e dico ma se anziché
continuare a classificare i cibi come
Buoni e Cattivi No la lasagna No il riso
in bianco così
il tiramisù no
la mela Sì la pizza no
l'insalatona Sì ma se ci fosse invece un
modo di cucinare la lasagna Ovviamente
con il ragù ovviamente con la
besciamella Ovviamente con il formaggio
con tutto quello con la pasta Ecco non
la lasagna di zucchine
bisogna avere no
se ci fosse il modo di cucinare tutto
ciò che amiamo
in un modo diverso senza cambiare gli
ingredienti senza cambiare il gusto in
modo che però abbia i valori
nutrizionali della dieta Beh io sarei la
persona più felice del mondo io potrei
dimagrire mangiando due dolci al giorno
io potrei quindi
accontentare questa signora facendole
provare una lasagna che ha più fibre un
indice glicemico più basso di un riso
integrale meno calorie meno Grassi
quindi che fa meglio del cibo dietetico
diciamo così e allora
dimagrire mangiando due dolci al giorno
il mio sogno
io sono golosissima e per me un giorno
senza un dolce è proprio un giorno
triste Quindi immaginatevi no pur di
essere brava come nutrizionista analisi
tutti a posto eccetera io avevo abolito
i dolci una tristezza terribile no
abbassare il colesterolo mangiando
Carbonara ma può essere qualcosa di
fattibile
Ecco che
pensai per fare questo io non posso
farlo da sola da un lato Andai negli
Stati Uniti ad approfondire la anti-age
Nutrition alla TAC University di Boston
che è la più quotata Per la nutrizione
della longevità perché mi interessava
molto vivere a lungo in una forma penso
che interessi a molti e li scoprì che
esiste negli Stati Uniti è stata
inventata e c'è da tantissimi anni la
culinari Medici la Harvard University
per esempio una delle prime che porta
avanti da anni la culinari Medici cioè
la medicina Calata nelle ricette
e dico Ma qui siamo vent'anni avanti
rispetto all'Europa rispetto all'Italia
Ma su che cucina applicano la medicina
sulla cucina americana vi potete
immaginare no
ho pensato devo essere io a portare in
Europa in Italia la culinary Medici
attraverso l'alleanza con i più grandi
del Gusto Ed ecco che fondo nel 2009 la
prima associazione no profit che unisce
insieme più grandi ricercatori e i più
grandi
più grandi scienziati ricercatori più
grandi chef e pasticceri italiani perché
Ricordiamoci che la cucina italiana è la
più buona del mondo e quindi su questo
dobbiamo sempre essere i primi
l'elenco degli chef stellati da internet
e di contattare senza conoscere nessuno
per puro caso risposero
Gualtiero Marchesi il maestro dei
maestri della cucina italiana con cui ha
avuto l'onore il piacere l'entusiasmo di
collaborare per otto anni e Massimo
Bottura
ovviamente seguirono tantissimi altri
tra cui anche Davide comaschi campione
del mondo di pasticceria per realizzare
insieme Che cosa il miracolo di una
cucina che soddisfa non Cinque Sensi Ma
sei sensi perché c'è il bello un bel
piatto il buono il profumo di una pianta
appetitoso
c'è il tatto di mangiare anche con le
mani
l'udito il canto magari di un soffritto
dell'acqua che bolle quando devo buttare
la pasta ma c'è un sesto senso quello di
alzarsi da tavola
leggeri anziché
sprofondare sul divano
schiantarsi sulla tastiera del computer
dopo pranzo perché abbiamo mangiato cose
buonissime Ma pesanti è una piacevole
sensazione di leggerezza che si realizza
soltanto quando alla cucina tradizionale
italiana
si aggiunge il benessere antiaging
Quindi
bisogna imparare a cucinare in un modo
più scientifico
ho riformulato in questi 15 anni Oltre
3000 ricette rendendole facile facili
veloci
fattibili da tutti anche dagli imbranati
in cucina e ci sono tante storie di
felicità iniziando dalla mia che ho
ripreso i chili che avevo a 18 anni e in
15 anni li ho sempre mantenuti anche
adesso che sono in menopausa e quindi
sapete che già uno Aveva il metabolismo
bloccato adesso ancora di più
quindi quando poi ho preso l'Oscar per
la salute nel campo dell'alimentazione
mio marito che è l'anima di tutto il mio
lavoro e che ringrazio con tutto il
cuore
mi disse Chiara questo deve diventare
anche ristorante ristoranti e quindi
abbiamo fatto la pazzia di aprire un
ristorante che
ha questa magia Cioè alla fine di un
passo con carbonara fritto tiramisù uno
prova quella sensazione incredibile di
leggerezza di sazietà ma di leggerezza
quella che normalmente
non c'è quando mangi qualcosa di di
goloso quindi
tutto questo diventa facile voglio darvi
qualche piccolo spunto come fare un
fritto che non assorba grassi si sfrutta
una legge fisica La sublimazione si può
preparare
l'alimento quindi per esempio una
cotoletta impanarla molto bene e poi va
abbattuta a meno 18 meno 20 gradi va
messa in congelatore
se frigio se friggiamo ehm da 100 da
meno 18 gradi a 160 gradi l'acqua
all'interno della carne o della del
pesce se vogliamo fare una cotoletta di
pesce sublima passa dallo stato solido
allo stato gassoso e questa fuoriuscita
di vapore dall'alimento impedisce
l'ingresso dell'olio è qualcosa di molto
semplice che potete fare anche voi a
casa L'importante è utilizzare l'olio di
girasole altoleico per friggere oppure
l'olio extravergine d'oliva ma diciamo
che costa un po' di più e perde comunque
tutti i suoi polifenoli durante la
frittura ed è importantissimo anche che
usare una friggitrice con termostato a
160 gradi e tamponare immediatamente il
fritto subito dopo che l'abbiamo scolato
Ecco questo è molto importante Oggi
andiamo su Marte Oggi abbiamo i
telefonini più
all'avanguardia è un peccato che invece
la cucina sia rimasta ai livelli di 50
60 70 anni fa la cucina può diventare
scientifica Anche perché la ricerca
scientifica ha scoperto che metodi di
cottura come la frittura o la soffritura
possono essere molto antiossidanti così
come la ricerca scientifica ha scoperto
che ci sono alcune sostanze cancerogene
che si possono formare durante la
cottura vedete che questa ciambella che
tra l'altro alle calorie di uno yogurt
è molto chiara Ecco Il marroncino che si
forma sui cereali sulle patate o
Purtroppo anche durante la tostatura del
caffè è altamente cancerogeno Pertanto è
fondamentale che impariamo tutti quanti
a casa a cucinare i cereali e le patate
in modo croccante chiaro goloso ben
cotto ma ecco non scuro Perché quel
marroncino e altrimenti è pericoloso per
la nostra salute
Beh cosa dirvi Io sono sono felice ho
risolto tantissimi problemi nella nella
mia vita non ho più lo stress di
sottopormi alla dieta e sono tantissime
le persone migliaia che seguono il mio
metodo scientifico per cucinare a casa
quindi quando siamo davanti ad un
problema e ci sembra impossibile la
soluzione quella di rendere più Golosi e
più sani i piatti tradizionali della
nostra cucina Ecco pensiamo che invece
se tutti i giorni ci diamo da fare per
realizzare questo miracolo poi alla fine
il miracolo si avvererà e io vi saluto
gustandomi la mia ciambella
[Applauso]